[buzzer alarms]
(Forrest voice-over)
Unlike most pillow fights,
this one would have to
take place in a County jail
where I was awaiting trial
for murder.
I requested a meeting
with the prison psychiatrist.
You wanted to see me
for something?
Yes, I think I have
figured out a way
to reform
the chronically violent.
I want to organize
a pillow fight.
And I know
that sounds crazy,
but the idea is that
it could divert
everyone's aggressive
feelings into harmless fun.
So what do you say?
May be worth a shot.
Is that a yes?
(Forrest voice-over)
Apparently that was a yes
because later that day
a guards versus prisoners
pillow fight
received official approval.
Did you see that? We're gonna
have a pillow fight on Tuesday.
You are all
cordially invited
to a prisoners versus guards
pillow fight.
It's gonna be
a little bit fun.
[laughs]
I'm pretty sure.
(Forrest voice-over)
The life of an accused murderer
behind bars
is a lonely
and frightening one.
This pillow fight seemed like
a good opportunity
to get to know people
and to take my mind
off of the terrible guilt
that was consuming me.
This pillow fight
was MacNeil's suggestion,
so let's all thank him
for coming up with
a new activity
for you all.
[applause]
- It's my pleasure.
All right, MacNeil,
this is your baby.
- You wanna start us off?
- Well, I mean, listen,
the great thing
about a pillow fight
is the simplicity of it.
My question for you is:
"Hey, who is ready to
feel like a kid again?"
[laughs]
Okay.
The other thing that I want
to tell you about pillow fights,
just so you're aware,
is that in a pillow fight,
you never know
when you might get
a sneak-attack.
[laughs]
I surprised you, right?
See that?
Okay...
Well, come on, now.
Oh, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Let's all join in.
All right?
Let's have a pillow fight!
[laughs]
- [grunts]
- Oh, [bleep]!
- [groans]
- Hey, hey, hey!
[grunting, groaning]
They're [bleep]ing weighted!
(Forrest voice-over)
I had not considered that
while these men may have been
novices at pillow fighting...
(Forrest)
Where did the weights
come from?
(Forrest voice-over)
They had expertise at smuggling
items into places
they did not belong.
Stop it! Stop it!
(Forrest voice-over)
Places like prisons...
and pillowcases.
The resulting melee
was a terrifying horror
- to behold.
- You set us up, MacNeil!
- What? I didn't do anything!
- Oh, you did!
[screams]
- [electricity crackles]
- [screams]
[police siren blaring]
Was it darkness
within the hearts
of the pillow fighters
that turned innocent
sleeping equipment
into improvised...
deadly weapons?
Or is pillow fighting
a twisted bloodsport
in disguise,
a feather-stuffed form
of combat that inspires
brutality in otherwise
gentle creatures?
No way to know for sure.
What I do know is that
my dreams of world peace
and my nose were shattered
together in one fell swoop.
And, so, I am forced
to give pillow-fighting...
just one--oh, sorry.
I want to get
the plies together.
Toilet paper.
- One star.
- Zing.